please to have here to my right long
time a head coach of the Cincinnati
Bengals as well as the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and a man who was here in
Southern California because he was part
of the Tournament of Roses Parade
rotting the Donate Life Rose Parade
Float good to see you Sam why how are
you sir
I'm doing fine we had a great time at
the Rose fridge and won the theme Awards
so we know that celebrating a victory
for that but it's a time where everyone
on that float was either a donor or
recipient mm-hmm I'm a recipient you're
a recipient you have somebody else's
heart beating inside I've got somebody
that kept took care of himself kept his
heart strong for me signed up when he
went to the driver's license bureau to
the DMV and said put that little
insignia on there if I ever die for some
reason car wreck or whatever and while
my organs donated and I got the heart
and it was really they said it had to be
either a first responder or military guy
an athlete somebody very strong I was 71
when I got the heart transplant was 72
now I'll be 73 but the next time I
interviewed by you because it's next
week for me but anyway he gave me a good
strong heart and I wrote actually 15
miles on a bicycle three weeks in five
days after the surgery I gave the
doctors were at Carolinas Medical Center
in Charlotte North Carolina and how
strong this heart is okay well I want to
make sure that we by the end of this
conversation make sure that everybody
understands what it means to donate and
how they can do that I'm here with Sam
watch here on the Rich Eisen show do you
want to talk a little bit of football
with him you got into coaching thanks to
none other than Bill Walsh Phil Walsh
was my coach when I was a rookie player
and in 1968 with the Cincinnati Bengals
we ran into each other later at another
venue and he said if I ever get a job I
want you to come be my a passing coach
and when he got the 49er job I was
working in Greenville South Carolina
it's my sports world I'm sure you've
bought many products there well I can
tell that laughs you haven't led anyone
oh I get my running shoes from them yeah
sure okay I got a call from bill and
this was literally after I received two
rejection
notices from two high schools in North
Carolina I decided I want to go back in
coach even if it was a high school is
gonna be fun and I was named the
director of the passing game by Bill
Walsh my bill walls right no you were
rejected locally in the Carolinas you
know one worth a dime yeah but he he was
really didn't want to give up that
coordinator ship job just yet but we
drafted some young kid out of Notre Dame
who really had not had much coaching
name Joe Montana and it put everything I
had into it and made him what he is
today well it's just you know how
because we discussed this you know
before you came out here it is amazing
football and how you can't make stuff up
that Bill Walsh was the guy who brought
you into coaching you were there when
Montana gets drafted and who's standing
on the other sideline when you are
coaching the Super Bowl for the
Cincinnati Bengals but they Lowe's and
Joe Montana what were you thinking about
when Montana gets the ball with last
last Drive Joe is a clutch player I knew
we were in for it I actually Dick LeBeau
was my defensive coordinator our
defensive coordinator first person
plural when you're a head coach they
talked that way but he's a terrific
coach and been around forever and knows
exactly what happens well we take a long
field goal really a threat on the edge
of the limit into the wind go up by
three points
leave him about three minutes much like
Atlanta and New England finished theirs
latest Super Bowl here and we I went
over to Bill and I had I was wired and
they had a camera me so they told me hey
don't go to your nose or your crotch and
then they said when you're when you're
talking you know know that you're being
heard so what's her language is whatever
I turned my back because they're coming
from across I said bring five and
mouthing bring five people I know that
system I helped I was there for the
first four years that was put in I
coached Joe I know his reads he bring
five he'll lay it off
we brought five he laid it off second
and eight and then we went into the
prevent and to dig Lobos credit we drop
a pass that would have won the game for
us with about 56 seconds left but if we
dropped it and I only had one time
left and then about two or three place
later John Taylor catches the winning
touchdown on a perfect pass and it was a
perfect play that won the game not a bad
defense that lost it Sam watch here on
the Rich Eisen show did you know when
you were coaching Collinsworth that he
had a broadcasters they could have done
anything he wanted to and Holly his wife
who's also a lawyer chris is a lawyer
has his law degree and I think they
together could do anything they wanted
to do terrific people likeable people
they would get along with anybody in any
industry and he talks to every level you
know he talks to that novice it doesn't
know much about the game then he talks
to the high school coaches listening in
trying to get a poor narrative and so
you knew that he had that sort of
talking ability because I did well what
was it what was it like coaching him you
had to be gentle because he might come
back and top you he he was a student of
the game
and he loved that love to study the game
and offer and I was what kind of a coach
that liked to get ideas from the players
they're the ones out there playing the
game the coaches don't play they stand
with her arms folded during the game and
then they try to get him ready at
practice but Chris would offer ideas and
I would use a lot of them and I ended up
having to be the guy that said Chris
it's time you know you may have lost a
step right here I got some young guys
coming up it's time and I actually in
effect cut him and he was not a happy
person I will tell you that but we have
been very close friends over the years I
talked to him a lot and he's a special
guy he's brilliant he's brilliant he's
brilliant and he's brilliant at what he
does Sam watch here and the rich eyes
that show and you have been fortunate
when you went into broadcasting Marv
Albert is my idol I mean I would not be
doing this job if I if it wasn't for
Marv growing up and watching him in the
New York City hear me too I'm in that
Club okay and you were with him for how
many years with him I was with him for
two or three years and then NBC lost the
contract to Fox
I went with ABC or CBS and Kevin Harlan
was my partner if you listen to Kevin he
sounds just like Marva yeah I mean and
he any calls NBA games just like my I
mean look we all world a little bit
derivative of Marv for a lot of us I
think she doll for him and then Enberg
you call games remember what was it like
working with dick who as we all know
passed away birds everything every every
nice thing everybody's saying about him
right now it's true he was the most
generally the most helpful he's the most
cooperative guy on and off he sent me a
Christmas card every year for the last
20 years we haven't been together you
know but I still get that Christmas card
I did just before he passed away this
year as well something else he's a
special guys well there are a lot of
good people in this business and they
all know the problems and the challenges
that each of us have you know to keep
going and do it right and present the
games or present the ideas as a show
like this would do then players and
coaches go through and then I think we
owe it to each other to support each
other as well well and then in that
regard let's talk about organ donation
let's talk about life as opposed to a
football life here sandwich so you had
cardiomyopathy correct at the ED back in
2000 I contracted viral which means a
virus somebody coughed in their hand I
shook their hand touched my eye only
about 5% of the population susceptible
to that I'm one of the 5%
lucky me and I survived it though for
about 16 years which is much longer than
the average so you knew at one point
when did you when you were told that you
need a new heart I was in the backyard
cutting down with a chainsaw some limbs
after a hailstorm freak hailstorm in
South Carolina and I got a little
vertigo you know a little dizzy and I
said he was what a coach thinks I said
jeepers I'm kind of chainsaw going wide
open above my head and I'm getting a
little bit dizzy if I drop this thing
I'm liable to ruin a brand new chainsaw
they had it two weeks so I went inside
and my wife said something's wrong with
you what's going on which shocked me
because the first time she ever noticed
I even came inside
she said we got to take you to the
doctor she knew I'd had the car of
course the cardio myopathy and the
doctors stood me to the Carolinas
Medical Center in Charlotte to the the
Sanger Heart and Vascular Institute they
immediately diagnosed it said you've got
a very dying heart you've only got a
little time left if we don't get a new
heart and that new heart came in on the
last day that I was supposed to be alive
in fact I'd already been scheduled to go
home with Hospice taking care of me
quote for as long as it took or for as
long as it's necessary it was the words
they use so you do not know whose heart
is inside you know this the donor
families call on that one they're
grieving remember anytime you get us
something new and you're celebrating
somebody out those grieving the death of
a loved one and that person when they're
ready that group of people mom and dad
maybe we have exchanged letters in code
code time a number there a number I
don't know where they are I don't know
what this person did I don't know if it
was a male or a female I don't fit as a
black or a white or some other
nationality I know that he has a strong
heart and I know that I'm taking care of
it and we'll continue to do so so what
would you say to somebody Sam white
she's out there listening watching this
show saying you know what I would want
to do that but it's it's kind of
something I want to you know I don't
want to be cut up when I would pass away
or something like that what do you say
to somebody who's got second thoughts
about donating I hear that a lot but
exactly what you said here's what I'd
respond look if I could ask you right
now while you're still mm-hmm
you know sane and and okay so my second
back to me later this year while you are
while you're sitting right here you
could say seven or eight lives and if
you could say 75 are not saved but
enhance the lives of 75 more people and
it wouldn't cost you a dime and it
wouldn't hurt because you will have
already passed away would you have an
objection to doing that I don't think
many people would say I don't want to do
it after that you mean you are giving
the gift of life you're leaving what
could be the greatest gift you can leave
mankind and that's to help
buddy else I would not be sitting here
talking to you if this one person was my
last chance I was down two minutes
before this heart got in me before I was
going to die
everything else was shutting down and
they were waiting for me to go ahead and
let go of the gurney I was holding on
with a will to live more than anything
else and it's as simple as it's not even
a website right I mean just you you or
there there could be oh there is but
there is one just register me or
register me talk okay and you or the DMV
essentially yeah they need to say I want
to sign up you're on the National
Registry anything ever happens to
register me org right before I let you
go talk to me about that day in in
Cincinnati where the snow balls are
coming down right and and and your
famous moment where you get to the
microphone and tell everybody you don't
live in Cleveland you live in Cincinnati
walked me through what was what happened
we yeah there had been an incident in
Denver the week before commissioner
sends out a you know memo don't let this
get started around the league throwing
snowballs they had the incident dimmer
actually they had to replay the down
because it was a field goal attempt and
hit right in front of the hold the next
week I think Jerry seaman was the
official on the sideline and we were the
officials were having a rough day
yeah we're playing - Seattle Seahawks
and they start their way our fans
started throwing a few snowballs and I
tell Jerry I said if you want me to stop
it I will you know I got the same memo
babe go do it and I went over and I got
Tom gave me this so it's your idea
saying give me a microphone yeah that's
the way my brain works right now and the
old Riverfront without thinking yeah it
was my I mean yeah I didn't know how I
couldn't yell up you know sure so I went
over I grabbed a mine I had no clue what
I was gonna do this was not
choreographed in any way shape or form I
said you know if you see anybody throw
anything on the field point them out
we'll get them out of here you'd only
been Cleveland you live in Cincinnati
and then I looked up at the owners box
saying I just lost or I just
and Paul Brown was knee-slapping
laughing just like you are right now and
I knew I was okay but I late later
though Bernie Kosar a quarterback for
the Cleveland Browns at that time his
dad and Big Dawg you know in the dog
pound yeah they helped me get together
for the Salvation Army in Cleveland we
raised $11,000 to kind of mend a fence
and a dunking booth and I can promise
you right now after Bernie hit me and
not me in the booth in March in
Cleveland shrinkage is a real reality
for all of us I'm telling you it was
cold but I did I started it off we had
these dog bones we beat him a couple of
times that year which was usual and I
said eat without a win cast the first
bone well they didn't read the Bible a
lot up there because nobody laughed they
got in line and they five bucks a throw
Bernie picked up a football the next
time nailed it first when I was in the
water
Sam White's you are the man thanks for
coming in register me org to save a life
register to donate your organs because
Sam Wyche is here on the Rich Eisen show
thanks to somebody's good grace good to
see you sir thanks that's Sam White's
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience